you know I have to say I'm pretty upset
today I just read I just read the news
that Berkeley City Council is getting
rid of a bunch of a bunch of a bunch of
offensive words from its city code which
it which is great for instance the word
manhole is is gone now in Berkeley it's
gonna be replaced with maintenance whole
and that's it I mean thank God right
because I can't tell you as a father of
a daughter I can't tell you how many
times my daughter has broken down in
tears because she's being excluded from
the language we use to describe sewers
it's is very traumatizing first so
they're solving that but it's not it's
not all good you see because Berkeley
has also gotten rid of any mention of
men and women from the code instead
replace replacing it with the word
people but wait a second people people
um
language like that is highly highly
offensive to furries like Beto how do
you think it makes them feel can you
imagine how excluded you would feel if
you identified as say a six foot tall
chicken and now everyone's going around
using a word like people
III think individual or entity I think
is probably even more I you want to be
as ambiguous as entity right would be
the more progressive choice so it's it's
Berkeley is they're getting there
they're there you know on the right path
but they have not progressed nearly
enough for my taste anyway so I just
wanted to mention that to begin with
okay much to discuss today and actually
we're gonna actually revisit the
discussion of furries a little bit later
because there's a there's gonna be a big
hit movie coming out a musical all about
furs and so which is another sign of our
decaying culture so I wanted to well
we'll talk about that later though but
first you know I think we can all agree
we should be able to all agree that that
we could all use more sleep right
especially those of us who are parents
you know as a parent your sleep time
however little there might be is very
precious and you want to make the most
of it you want to you want to pack in
much sleeping as you can in those two
and a half to three hours that you get
and that's where Boleyn branch comes in
getting a great night's sleep has never
been easier thanks to the world's
softest sheets brought to you by Boland
branch everything ball and branch makes
from bedding to blankets is made from
pure 100% organic cotton which means
they start out supersoft and they get
even softer over time everyone who tries
Boleyn branch just loves them that's why
they have over a thousand five-star
reviews you can go check it out for
yourself their sheets are even loved by
three US presidents they want you to
love your purchase too so they offer a
no risk 30-day trial and free shipping
which means if you don't like them you
can send them back but you're not going
to not like them okay because there's no
better option out there you're gonna
love them once you sleep on their sheets
you're not gonna want to sleep on
anything else so to get you started
right now my listeners get $50 off your
first set of sheets at Boleyn branch com
promo code mat go to Boleyn branch calm
today for $50 off your first set of
sheets that's bol l and branch comp
promo code mat Boleyn branch calm promo
code mat alright so let me begin here
not gonna spend much time on this which
which is what I always say before I
ramble about something for 57 minutes
I'll try to have better follow-through
this time though we've talked this week
quite a bit about Trump and Trump
related issues and I have criticized
Trump god forbid
that's something that I do on occasion
maybe you've noticed but as always when
those occasions arise people get upset
it has I guess been decided by people
other than myself that my job is to
obsequious ly justify and defend
everything Trump does or says that's
that's my job according to him now
personally I would rather be dead than
sacrificed my intellectual integrity for
the sake of a politician if I'm gonna
sacrifice my intellectual integrity for
anything it's not gonna be for a
politician I I see I would choose death
over that I really would I just I can't
I who would want to live like that
so that's just a difference of opinion
though though I suppose with me with
with with other people the point is I've
gotten a lot of feedback shall we say
this week and a lot of people asking a
lot of people asking saying you know so
are you a trump supporter or not what
are you one of those dastardly
nevertrump errs is that what you are
what's up with all the criticism and so
on it seems kind of late in the game to
be having this conversation almost three
years in but I guess it still needs to
be had so that's fine I wanted just
briefly for those who have been asking
explain my strategy or maybe by my
philosophy my philosophy of Trump
philosophy of Trump that's my that's
what I'm going to explain it's very
simple okay it goes like this when it
comes to Trump
I will criticize him when I think he's
wrong which he is wrong sometimes and
that's because he's not God he's not a
perfect being he can be wrong he's
fallible and so when he as I say so when
he's right when he does and says a good
thing in my opinion I defend him and he
is right sometimes because he's not
Hitler he's not Satan he can be right
and when he is I say so and that's it
really that's the whole thing that's the
whole that's that's the kitten caboodle
super simple agree I say so disagree I
say so there you go the end that's all
it's not it's not virtue signaling it's
not putting on a show it's not trying to
appeal to this or that group and this is
a no it's just I'm just I say what I
think if I disagree I say that's it
that's really it am i I never Trump er
no I I don't even know what that label
means that's the dumbest label never
he's in office and maybe you've noticed
he's president so even if I wanted to be
a never Trump er I wouldn't know how to
be one what do you mean never what
exactly he's there he won
he's so what do you mean never what am I
never dif I was a never Trump what what
what is it that I'm never doing he's
it's it's not like we have to go and
vote for him again every single day that
he's in office this so that's not an
issue on a day to day basis while he's
in office
what would being an ever
shopper entail if it me if it entails if
the never means never support him never
agree with him under any circumstance
then that's just insane and and I and
there are some people some so-called sub
kids conservatives so maybe former
conservatives who have taken that
approach and have decided basically to
become liberals I mean really become
liberal and to it to accept liberal
ideas and to support the Democratic
Party because they hate Trump so much I
guess that's what a never Trump are is
now and that is just a ridiculous point
of view that this idea that you're going
to now accept an entirely different
philosophy and ideology just because you
don't like one guy who subscribes to the
other ostensibly subscribes anyway to
the other philosophy that that doesn't
make any sense so I'm not that I'm all
but in my a Trump fan no I'm not a Trump
fan because I'm not a fan of any
politician as I've said many times
fandom and politics don't mix you want
to be a fan of someone then be a fan of
a sports star be a fan of a sports team
be a fan of a rock star be a fan of a
band but pom-poms don't belong in
politics leave your pom-poms at home
when it's time to talk about politics I
don't think that we should ever be a fan
of any politician period in my a trump
supporter well even to that I would say
know it because it's because of this my
support for Trump just like for any
politician is completely conditional I
have no loyalty to politicians none
whatsoever I'm loyal to my family I'm
loyal to my wife to my kids there are
people to which I am loyal there are
situations where I think loyalty is
important but politics is not one of
them I am absolutely not loyal to any
politician because they work for me and
they work for you or they work for us
that's what how that's how this is
supposed to work
they're supposed to earn our support on
a day to day basis continue earning it
the the bank account is basically always
empty because it's the
they earn it and then but they could
lose it the next day so they're really
not it's it's politicians they're not
building up much much you know they're
not they're not accruing much wealth and
in that department they have to keep
earning it every single day because the
thing is we know about politicians is
they can flip-flop they can change they
can betray their promises they can do
all that the politicians do it all the
time which is why I think we should
never stake out a position as well I'm
the supporter of this person I support
them in this situation right now given
what they're doing but that could change
tomorrow in which case I'm gonna kick
them to the curb because I have no
emotional attachment I have no affection
it is totally transactional finally it's
like you're doing what I want right now
I agree with you right now I support you
but if you if you stray you're done
that's my approach that's that's my
formula that's what I that's how I
approach as I said every politician
period this is this is this is the way I
look at it I don't make exceptions for
anybody and I think that look we all
have our own approaches I of course I'm
biased in favor of my own but I do think
that this is actually kind of the right
way of going about it as an American I
think this is what our founders had in
mind they had in mind for us to be
skeptical of anyone in power be
skeptical of anyone in power for the
simple fact that they're there because
they wanted to be in power if they have
power in America it means they wanted
power and so we should be skeptical of
them that's that's
the catch-22 of politics is that you
know you could I forget the quote from
someone who now I've totally forgotten
it so I'm gonna completely mangle it but
you know the the people who are least
suited for power are precisely the kinds
of people who would pursue power and
that's that's just that's the catch-22
so the very fact that someone who pursue
it means that we should be skeptical
because we should be saying well what
hold on a second what are you so
desperate to be in charge for what's
going on here and so we always maintain
that skepticism at all times I think
that's that's just the way I look at it
all right
Democrats in the in the house yesterday
passed the raise the wage act which
would hike the federal minimum wage to
15 bucks an hour it's not gonna be taken
up in the Senate so it's not going to
become law but it could become law
eventually if Dems take control this is
one of the many horrible things they
plan to do and I do think it's horrible
I I know it's a it's it seems on the
like so many Democratic policies
especially in the economic realm it
seems on the surface compassionate and
like they're concerned about working
Americans and so on but when you stop to
think about it for just five seconds you
realize how bad it really is so a couple
of thoughts here on the minimum wage
since it's being discussed I I do
support a minimum wage but the minimum
wage that I support is zero
I think zero is the baseline zero should
be the minimum which I definitely don't
think the minimum wage it shouldn't go
below that okay so there shouldn't be a
negative nobody should be charged money
to work so I'll say that but zero is the
cutoff zero is the baseline should be
the baseline wage for work because
that's the baseline amount of effort you
can put in it's possible for someone to
do zero work which means that they have
earned zero dollars do zero work at zero
dollars I think that makes a lot of
sense but when you skip
from zero and you go all the way up to
say $8 an hour minimum wage $10 now or
$15 an hour 20 to 25 I mean there's
there's no limit to it once you do that
it doesn't really make any sense because
what you're what you're suggesting is
it's basically impossible for someone to
do less than that amount of work in an
hour you're saying that if the minimum
wage is 15 hours now you're saying that
it's impossible that anyone in America
could do work for an hour and the work
they perform could be worth less than
$15 you're saying that's impossible all
the work that's being done across the
country in any given hour all of it is
worth at least $15 now I I just I don't
think that's true
I'll give one example we could all point
out examples but just one example I went
to McDonald's the other day as I have
the unfortunate habit of doing on
occasion and McDonald's now most of
McDonald's I go and now have those
automated things where you can order the
touchscreen things but I usually avoid
those because they're touchscreen and so
you can see the finger smudges on them
and it's I don't want to touch that
thing I mean how often are those things
washed it looks like they're never
washed I don't want to put my hand on
thing up 100 other people have touched
right before I'm about to eat it's gross
when I can see their gross greasy
disgusting hand marks on it so then I
went to the to the cashier and so here's
how that interaction work that that
interaction went verbatim and as I said
we've all had interactions like this so
I walk up the cashier he goes can I help
you yes I'll have the large number one
please thank you that it yes
that's 657 actually sorry can you can
you change that to a medium okay and
that's all what now let me ask you
somebody like that someone who that's
all
they do that is the amount they can't
even be trouble to enunciate their words
and they can barely even put in the
effort to speak they are these the
barely sentient there you go you're
almost watching them melt in front of
you into this just lump of matter like
they they're barely even there because
of how because of just how dis how
utterly disinterested they are and it
not only disinterested but but but
ticked off that you're there you know
the kind of person where you going on
these places and they make their so
unpleasant and so miserable that they
make you regret coming and you are less
likely to come back because of people
like that you you they make you feel
guilty for being there where you start
to question yourself you start saying
out Jesus I mean I should you start
feeling bad like maybe I should have
just gone and hunted for deer or
something for my lunch I don't want to I
feel like I'm putting this person out or
something but this is their job this is
what they do they they came in they put
on the visor they put on the name check
this is all theirs this is all they can
do this is what they're getting paid to
do you might as well put a little effort
and they don't want to put any effort in
so with someone like that are they worth
are they worth fifth automatically worth
is doing that
sighing rolling your eyes is that
automatically worth $15 an hour
especially when there's a machine that
can do exactly that without the attitude
and speaking clearly I mean how could it
possibly be worth 50 it's not it's not
worth $8 now somebody like that I guess
the the company this is the restaurant
of the store has some need for them
that's why they're still there so you
know they're what are they worth fifty
cents an hour at most 25 cents they're
worth it very close to zero maybe not
zero but very close to it and so that
they should be paid that's what they
should be paid people should be paid
according to the work they do now on the
other hand you do have occasions and
usually this happens in a chick-fil-a as
we all know but not always there are
times when you go to a fast food place
and the cashier is super nice
helpful and cheerful and they've got a
smile on their face and they they you
know something screwed up or you have to
make a change and they're they're just
very accommodating and welcoming and
they make you feel good they make you
feel they make you want to order just
more food just to just to reward them
which they make you want to come back
they just they're there they have their
doing they're putting in maximum effort
right I mean you're you're punching
things into it to a into a cash register
the way that they make these things
investors it's like that it's they're
just pictures of the things you don't
haven't even have to read so someone
like that they they know they could be
putting in almost no effort instead they
put in all of the possible effort they
can into this job dick because they're
saying to themselves look this is what
I'm doing it's not what I want to do
with the rest of my life I don't
particularly enjoy it I wouldn't do it
for free
but since I'm doing it since this is
what I'm getting paid to do I might as
well do it you good job and so that's
what they do now someone like that I
think those are people who I mean they
could be worth $30 a night that you they
could be worth $50 an hour if they're
that good at their job and they're and
they make you as a customer want to come
back they're worth a lot of money to the
company because they're there making
money for the company so I think you get
rid of the minimum wage and here's
here's what the situation should be
behind any fast food counter it should
be a situation where there are people
working back there who are making $35 an
hour and there are people who work over
making thirty five cents an hour
that's how wide the gap should be
between wages because that's how wide
the gap in effort is and the wages
should reflect that so this isn't just
about punishing the fast-food employees
are the minimum wage employees who put
in no effort it's not just about about
it not even punish you it's it's it's
not about simply encouraging them to do
better although that is part of it but
it's also about rewarding those who are
worth a lot more than $8 an hour or $15
now or 20
now when you have a minimum wage what
ends up happening is because the the
company the the the restaurant you know
they they've got these employees who are
worth almost nothing they have to pay
them though eight ten fifty dollars an
hour which means they've got to take
that potential income away from the
employees who could be worth more you
get rid of the minimum wage and now yeah
they're gonna be people who lose out and
deserve to lose out because they're
they're just lumps of matter sitting
there but then those who are worth more
now you've freed up that capital and and
they can be paid what they're worth so I
think it and it's then if you if you
work at a Burger King or something and
there's no minimum wage and you find
that all of a sudden you're getting paid
two dollars an hour because you're just
a miserable employee who puts in no
effort and makes everyone around you
feel terrible just for being well then
you could look at your at your
co-workers or make it so much more you
could say oh I want it that's what I
want well it's very simple to get there
all you have to do is put in the effort
all right um what else do we have here
this is an incredible story I wanted to
mention from NBC Los Angeles calm we
just read a little bit of this
it says small business owners in San
Diego County are sounding an alarm over
thousands of dollars in losses to
shoplifters the problem is that these
shoplifters don't appear to be facing
any consequences a 7-eleven franchise
owner told NBC 7 that every single day
shoplifters come in and take what they
want if they can keep it under a certain
amount the owner hopes the city will
step in to do something the reason why
is is happening under Prop 47 which
passed in 2014
anything stolen below a 950 dollar value
keeps the crime at a misdemeanor which
means that an
getting arrested to the misdemeanor so
under this under this Prop 47 California
what that means is that people you know
if you if you steal under nine hundred
fifty dollars worth of worth of stuff
that's a misdemeanor and you're just
going to get a citation which we've
people are just strolling into 711s and
other convenience stores in California
and taking whatever they want in fact
what what brought this to my attention
attention is that there is a video which
I can't play because there's so much of
all Garrity in it that I'd have to bleep
it out you wouldn't understand what was
even being said but somebody took a
video I think it's from a 7-eleven where
this guy this this Punk strolls in and
just take something and leaves and no
one stops him because they can't the
most the police can do is just oh you
shouldn't have done that in an issue a
citation that's it this is this is crazy
and it shows again that you have these
policies that are supposed to be
compassionate and uh you know we're
trying to prevent we don't want to lock
people in jail for nonviolent crimes but
these supposedly compassionate policies
look what they're doing where is the
compassion for the business owners who
are now losing merchandise and are
living in fear because they know that
anyone can walk in and take their stuff
at any time it's it's outrageous
all right speaking of outrageous I'm
moving along here kind of quickly mostly
because there there are some some great
emails I wanted to get to on a Friday
one other thing a bunch of new trailers
came out yesterday for some reason and
one that a lot of people been talking
about is that the trailer for the new
Top Gun movie with Tom Cruise comes back
and reprises his role and now I have to
admit I have to confess that I have
never seen Top Gun I don't even know
what Top Gun is about I I gather that he
flies a plane I don't know what to what
end I mean what's the central it does he
fight aliens
an alien thing if so I'll watch it but I
get the impression that there's no
aliens and it's not even he's a fighter
jet but is he fighting anybody does he
is there are there does that even happen
I from the little brief glimpses of Top
Gun I've seen I just don't understand
the point I've never seen it I have no
interest but that's coming out there's
also something else the film version of
the musical Cats is coming out and this
trailer was released it honestly is and
I've got to give a parental warning here
because a warning for everybody
trigger warning the this this looks like
the most disturbing terrifying film
unintentionally but potentially the most
disturbing and terrifying film that has
ever been made I thought that the
Exorcist was a scariest movie of all
time until I saw this trailer watch this
[Music]
[Music]
I haven't seen you before have I oh and
if you find the meaning
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you going to try for a different
life
[Music]
see that that's horrific isn't it hey
what is that it does first of all look
like furries the musical it looks like a
musical for it that's what it looks like
but also what is this art is it Joe I
mean who would watch that completely
terrifying it disturbs me down to such a
- to my core I can't even describe it
who could like cats enough I mean cats
the animals to watch that really really
awful stuff but I figured I had to
endure that so therefore I'm gonna make
you endure it as well alright let's go
to emails Matt well show at gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com this is from
Jonathan says dear mr. Walsh I knew this
I know this is kind of late I have been
falling behind on yours and mr.
Shapiro's videos how dare you Jonathan
get your act together
okay what are you doing with your life
however this is about the whole aerial
casting controversy I wanted to know if
you ever thought that some people like
me are upset not because we are racist
but because it is portraying a character
that we already have a physical image of
and what we grew up seeing I personally
don't like it when Hollywood changes the
images of the typical character on a
name film such as spider-man changing
three times I also wanted to mention
that I am NOT white so by the leftist
logic I cannot be considered a racist
for not for not liking the fact that
they casted a black actor I grew up with
erielle being white and now they want to
change it for political correction I
personally like to see characters
portrayed as they are when it's first
imaged that's all thank you for your
time and Godspeed yeah I mean there's a
perfectly reason to but agree but
there's a perfectly reasonable
justification for being not a huge fan
of the fact that they changed ariel - in
fact i've heard one thing i've heard was
we talked about this whatever was last
week two weeks ago i heard from several
women who said that they have red hair
and so ariel was the only disney
princess with red hair and as a little
girls dave you know that meant something
to them so they liked the fact that the
princess looked a little bit like them
had red hair and
yeah they don't like the fact that that
they changed her for that reason but
yeah I can understand that it's kind of
like yeah they're fictional characters
so it doesn't matter they can look like
anything but it's sort of like when
you've got a long-running show and one
of the actors bails or is fired or
whatever quits and so they bring in a
different actor to play that same role
which you don't find happening that
often these days but I think it used to
happen more often the one example it
pops mind the Fresh Fresh Prince of
bel-air which course is a great show I
love that show growing up but aunt Aunt
Viv
they changed midway through they changed
actors and brought in a totally
different woman to play the same person
and yeah that throws you free I wasn't a
fan of that it throws you for a loop
even though it's a fictional character
it's still like that's this is a
different person it doesn't look like
the other person how am i you you you've
you've broken the fourth wall you've now
made me remember that I'm just watching
some some fake thing and that's not good
it takes away enjoyment so yeah I could
understand I can understand that
generally if you're gonna do the live
adaptation of a cartoon it makes sense
that you're looking for someone who
looks sort of like the cartoon just just
to keep that continuity going right this
is from who's this from I don't think I
got a name I forgot to write the name
that says I'm dating my I'm I am dating
myself as a listener of yours but I
remember on a post you made back on the
Matt Walsh blog entitled I wasn't ready
for marriage and how you met your wife
on he harmony I'm a 26 year old grad
student who is also looking and coaching
and working in coaching and I'm having a
hard time meeting nice young available
men I've been very hesitant and trying
online dating as I can never figure out
how to answer tell me about yourself
questions I also have a hard time
believing that an authentic friendship
to build with someone you met online due
to a common interest like biking or the
Green Bay Packers I signed up for
Catholic match now I have an inbox full
of messages from guys in my area that
are all basically asking me hey it's
cool that you like blank tell me more
about yourself and I'm feeling pretty
hopeless how were you able to find
someone you really clicked with and
eventually married on a dating site
how can online dating not be basically
self marketing also may
could you ask Ben to take to make a
daily wired dating site for its
listeners I just love these shows and
I'm sure a bunch of us like like-minded
daily wire Ian's could pair up and breed
a formidable conservative army I like
that idea so we're breeding forget about
conservative army I don't care about
that we're breeding new listeners so
that we can dominate for decades so
we're just gonna keep sorry that's a
good idea maybe I'll talk to Ben about
that as far as the dating sites well
first of all I would say the messages
you're getting from guys on Catholic
match seem do kind seem kind of boring
and bland
it could be worse though from what I've
heard from women if you were on some
other sites the messages your inbox may
be filled with other sorts of things so
maybe I would look at the bright side
there yeah it does look I'm a big
believer in online dating that is how I
met my wife I think it's this was eight
years ago that the scene has changed
quite a bit with online dating evolved
or maybe devolved so I in one hand I
can't speak to it that much because I
just haven't seen it I haven't been in
it for for so long but I do think that
this is just how in fact I I saw I wish
I had the chart in for me I saw a chart
recently that was charting going back to
like the 50s charting how people met
their spouses and there's all these
different options like met him at work
you met him through connections with
family you met him in high school or at
school or you met him online and of
course back in the 50s nobody was
meeting online because I didn't exist
but what you find is that the Internet
comes onto the scene in the mid-90s
and then people meeting their spouses
online is just shot through the roof
where now it's one of the most common
ways for people to meet it's just it's
incredible how this thing has changed
this fundamental aspect of human
existence how we meet our mates right
and I do think that it's when you think
of all the potential ways to meet
someone and when I was dating before I
was married I met people through work I
met people through school it just like
anybody else but I think online
dating provides you at least for me here
was a thing for me I got to a point
where I wasn't looking to just date
anymore just for the sake of dating I
was looking to I was looking to get
married I was looking to move on to that
next stage in my life I wasn't just
gonna marry the first person I came
across but I was look I wanted to get
into a relationship where that is the
end goal where we're kind of both trying
this out to see if we want to get
married and where we have that where we
both have that end goal in mind we're
both serious mature adults and that's
where we want to head if it works out
that's what I was looking for and I
found that if you find the right online
dating site it works for that and so for
me when I met my wife we you know I knew
within like a week that I'd probably
that we're gonna get married because I
think that when you meet someone you
kind of know and when you when you click
like that at least for me I think you
figure it out pretty quickly just like
if you think of all the failed
relationship you've been and even if you
dated someone for years and then end up
not working out if you think back you
probably knew really soon that it acted
that this probably wasn't gonna go
anywhere even if you're stuck with it
for a while for me the way that I cut
through all the noises that I was just
with my wife and she was the same with
me when I met her we were very upfront
with each other we we didn't waste a lot
of time with small talk we got we kind
of got down to talking about the serious
things what our goals are we were very
upfront
we're both upfront about our end goals
we were looking for someone we're
looking for marriage for a serious
relationship we were seeing we were open
about that with each other I don't know
if they say on first dates you're not
supposed to talk about politics or
religion that's pretty much the only
thing we talked about we talked about
things like that and the fact that we we
lined up so much there but also that she
wanted to talk about those things that
for me told me okay well this is this is
the person so I don't know if that helps
you at all but that was my own
experience all right this is from
Nikolas says hi Matt what are your
thoughts on Kant's critique of the
ontological argument for God's existence
the ontological argument claims that if
if it is possible that God exists in any
possible world that he exists in all
possible worlds
Kant's criticism of this argument is
that it falsely treats existence as a
predicate and that therefore does not
follow from his possible existence in
any possible world that God exists in
all possible worlds do you agree or
disagree with this critique I think I've
talked about the ontological argument
before I do I agree with the critique I
think that the ontological argument is
absurd I think it's it's a lot of
brilliant men have advanced this
argument it was originally formulated by
saying Ansem whose was clearly a
brilliant man but I think that it's not
a brilliant argument it is uh it is
absurd it's absurdly weak because it
seems to try and conjure God into
existence through word games that's what
it seems like it seems like a word game
that's how it strikes me where you say
to someone okay imagine the greatest
possible being and they say okay I'm
imagining it and you say well well that
being must exist why is that because
it's greater to exist that not exist
never that doesn't make any sense well
you said you imagine the greatest
possible being didn't you yeah well then
he has to exist otherwise you didn't
imagine the greatest possible being but
you did imagine the great possible being
so then he exists that's that's how the
ethnological are game or it's it's it's
one of those arguments that it's it's
almost hard to rebut because it's so bad
because you don't even know where to
begin when it's you're trying to figure
it's so self-evidently wrong that you
almost don't that's like if someone asks
you to define the word the it would take
you a second is like what else it define
you're just it's so obvious that it's
hard for a minute to break down my
favorite response to this argument is
the earliest one when santan some first
developed it a monk I forget his name
but a contemporary pointed out that you
could use this argument to prove the
existence of literally anything in the
example he gave is the greatest possible
island he said well you know you could
imagine the greatest possible you could
imagine what would constitute the
greatest possible island and by this
arguments logic that would mean that
that island must logically exist because
you imagined it and that's just not how
it work I think maybe a more modern
example would be and
the problems with that rebuttal is that
well an island is not a being it's not a
person and so what constitutes being the
greatest island is very different from
the sorts of things that would require
you to be the greatest possible being or
person so let's let's let's use a an
example that I think relates more
imagine what imagine the greatest
possible basketball player greatest
possible vessel the greatest possible
basket player but we can all kind of we
he's nine feet tall he can jump across
the entire court he can hit any shot
from any distance he's faster than the
speed of light I mean he's basically
Superman except for the nine feet tall
bit that's the greatest possible
basketball player well by the
ontological argument if you have
imagined that basketball player he must
exist because it is greater to exist
than not exist and therefore if he's the
greatest possible basketball player then
he has to exist but so it doesn't make
any sense
that basketball player doesn't he's
imaginary so you might say so if now as
you mentioned this argument treats
existence as an attribute as a
personality or or a characteristic
almost or you say well the greatest
possible being has to be all loving
all-knowing all-powerful and he also has
to have the trait of existence well
that's not really what existence is
existence is not a trait it's not it's
not a quality existence just is
existence is to be that's what existence
is so to say that greatness or or so I'm
sorry to say that existence is a quality
that falls under the umbrella of
greatness that to me doesn't make any
logical sense and besides who says that
it's greater to exist and not exist I
don't know I mean maybe it's great or
not to exist I don't know
Superman is pretty powerful because he
doesn't exist you can be whatever you
want him to be so it doesn't make it
now maybe so if you're saying that
existence is a necessary contingent for
something being the greatest possible
being then maybe that means maybe that
simply just means it's not possible to
imagine the greatest possible being
that's all that means that's all you've
really proven is that you well you can't
actually imagine the greatest possible
thing and in fact that's true of God we
can't when you say imagine the greatest
possible being you can't really imagine
God you don't really know what that
means we can say God's all-powerful gods
all-knowing well we can't really
comprehend that or imagine hit or
understand what it means so there's a
problem there - the only thing I will
say about the ontological argument in
its in its favor I suppose sort of is
that it is an it is an argument that
tries to establish the logical necessity
of God and in theory I understand the
the attraction to that kind of argument
so I think that that's a good sort of
argument to make well a logical
necessity argument I just think that
this is the wrong one this doesn't do it
but the attraction to a logical
necessity argument is is that it's it's
much stronger is that if you can
successfully make an argument that God
is logically necessary then you have
proven he exists because he is logically
necessary as opposed to most of the
arguments for God that you hear
especially from most apologists out
there like William Lane Craig or any of
those guys if you watch one of their
debates they're not making arguments
from logical necessity they're making
arguments they're making evidentiary
arguments they're making arguments
they're saying okay well here's all the
evidence and I think that that leads to
the conclusion that God exists but it's
because it's not logically necessary by
those arguments you are you are allowing
the possibility that maybe he doesn't so
what you're really saying is when you
point to the fine-tuning argument or the
argument from the first cause or any
other well you're
based on these facts it is more likely
than not that God exists or it is most
plausible that God exists which i think
is still a good argument but I think the
reason some people aren't comfortable
with it is that it's well more likely
than not still leaves the knot because
you can't really point to fine-tuning
and say I have proven based on this 100%
God exists because you haven't there are
means someone you you could someone
could come up with a thousand different
potential scenarios they may not be
plausible scenarios they may not be true
they may not be likely but you could
come up with scenarios to explain the
fine-tuning that don't involve God and
so I think with the with the logical
necessity argument you're trying to cut
all that out and say forget about that
let me make this logical no so logical
necessity is like if I were to say that
every every square in the world has four
sides that is that is a statement of
logical necessity it's not evidentiary
it's just by definition every square
must have four sides otherwise it's not
a square and so I'm right I have proven
it I've proven my point just by saying
that's what the ontological argument is
trying to do I respect the effort and I
like the idea of making logical
arguments for God's existence
I just don't as I said I don't think
that does it that's not that's not it
that ain't it chief as the as the kids
would say all right we will um we will
leave it there have a great weekend
everybody Godspeed
today on the Ben Shapiro show president
from disavows to send her back crowd
chants and the media proved their
hypocrisy that's today on the bench
Shapiro show